questo gioco si basa su gente di terra
di russia però prima sigla
[Musica]
no
finalmente ho cambiato maglia e negli
ultimi 10 vi dovevo la stessa maglia e
perché io registrati tutti di fila anche
oggi avevo sempre con la maglia prolo
cambiata per far sembrare che non puzza
in realtà anche oggi avrei usato quella
invece ha messo questa che è allegra
quella di ragazzi venuti questo video
sono famiglie che oggi siamo su come che
si chiama parola l'aifo floris super
slam
ok credo sia tipo un troll facebook più
o meno un professionista in realtà non
lo so però proviamoci number one
non so quante cose si chiusero appena
sentito dio non ho capite una sega di
quello che a breve
lui lui e boris e attraverso la vita di
boris ne scopriremo come è fatta la
russia credo credo siate punto al fisco
e comunque schiaccio sulle cose sono
ancora in tempo per cambiare gioco
dobbiamo continuare sta cosa
no perché è un troll face quest x 10 di
difficoltà tra cibi un attimo che clic
sul quindi io devo cliccare su
determinate cose e sblocca e pietro
facebook
se questa bottiglia che è cliccabile a
del grano sopra questa bottiglia cosa
che cosa mi significa devo lasciare b
quindi cosa devo fare esattamente in
strada ne andiamo avanti schiaccia
tastiera c'è un lusso che per la
scrivania che vi hanno rubato una tazza
che diavolo in tutto questo cosa vacca
la vera rischia grandissimo lo so come
ho fatto a fare sta roba
va bene il primo livello lo abbiamo
fatto ragazzi già un traguardo per
l'umanità dovrà sicuro next level
vediamo che cosa esce fuori
raga non capisco imi e di quello che
dice non capisco niente neanche una
parola però mi fa ridere mi fa ridere
come parla comunque devo fare cose che
non ci si aspetta la vediamo è una
matrioska questa eccolo
il baby slam devo schiacciare qualche
pulsante si pronuncia una leva qui
io sono un fenomeno
ho scoperto il mio talento altro che è
forte né the rocket league sono qui su
questo gioco se la sega cosa dici è
scappato e sta sopra questa poi non ho
capito come ci siamo
non si capisce una sega vabbè andiamo
avanti pantaloni felpa in pesce che di
pesce perché stai piangendo vecchio e
riproviamo
siamo sulle rive del network famosissimo
disney per cinque chilometri orari
130 bottiglia
c'è una sirena io che valga flop ma non
chiedetemi ma vabbè la fetta equa i
pantaloni sono qua devo trovare
qualcos'altro sicuro il sacchetto la
gomma e le scarpe adesso completo
perfetto diamo altri ragazzi sempre
sempre più slavi non ho capi giuro che
andiamo avanti
salve bonuomo mi vende qualcosa cos'è
che stava prendendo docente archetti a
devo riparare la macchina ha chiaro
bulloni bulloni servono no questo sarà
urti fatto ma già la macchina è partita
zio perché allora non dovevo fare così
devono imparare la macchina immagino
però evitare anche che me la porta non
so se questo può cambiare qualcosa e
clicco su di lui si mette a ballare al
ritmo ci sta tutto
ciao mi dai una mano a circa solio
sporco demonio che è stato messo il
paraurti di schianti ora devo riuscire a
questa parte difficile ma devo riuscire
a farcela ma vedi che cosa che ho messo
su sti cosi regala la vasta perché mi
fotte la macchina devo ammettere
qualcosa nella macchina in modo tale che
non me la fottano però non ho capito
cosa di preciso se per me è un mix di
elementi e che fanno sì che vi non parta
con la nostra non ho capito esattamente
quali chiama anatolij per aiuto va bene
allora maledetti pezzenti che fottono le
macchine fermati femme
mettiti un nuovo nel caso del tubone non
lo so stato aliquota mente un oggetto
cambia musica spiegano prova a mettere
così vediamo niente mi parte la macchina
tra tutti questa è veramente un casino
nuova alle uova hanno messe sicuro
dentro manca non lo so questo sapendo
che queste ventina crisi da fuoco
sventato io però c'è e siamo a cinque
livelli ragazze sono sei in totale
quindi non male no schiacciato il meno
un cavolo mi voglio perdere voglio
rivedermi l'ubs voglio perdere fondi
terra va bè ragazzi si fermer ci siamo
fermati in lituania è chiaro che allora
la soluzione è la prima una di queste
porte fatemi entrare maledetti lituani
questa roba perché si apre cofano tra
l'altro zia mi fa mi fai entra per
favore per favore te lo chiedo niente al
momento è difficilissimo suo livello
mette alla prova le mie capacità
videoludiche in un modo che mai prima o
morto subito emesso un secondo a morire
vane lituano che alimenta le macchine
giustamente blues passion next level
ragazzi numero 6
io continuo a capire ancora meno
dell'inizio prova lente devo fermare le
macchine a devo fare l'autostop
sono diventato un vecchio sono morte di
autostop va bene non facciamo
l'autostadt facciamo altro devo riuscire
a farmi dare un passaggio come faccio
tappa i buchi
c'è un russo nel buio della buca sono
degli slavi nella buca va bene è
importante saperlo
ecco birra e patatine e l'estonia è
conquistata credo spero
no no no porca vacca farlo quasi subito
perché sennò si si si parte il tempo a
caso va bene che vada flags robin
roberts severità prendile ecco perfetto
gli offri la la gente tipo ma poi
offrirle al tipo nella bozza
bene
e vabbè il trono di slavi next level che
noi e che sia finito a questo punto
eccolo li prendo un po di questo grazie
prendo anche un po di chili di che è
successo tipo di dj si e suicidato ma
pensavo fosse finito al sesto livello
invece non finisce
prendi un po di questo live complici poi
sono stato bravissimo non ho capito
manco io cosa potevo fare ma l'ho fatto
livello 8 a mosca poche parole e si è
ubriacato e si è risvegliato qui chiaro
dobbiamo andare a mosca ma la macchina è
persa non ho soldi quindi devo trovare
un modo per arrivare a mosca ci sono i
miei amici della festa lassù prestatemi
dei money su capri e taglia ancora che
fanno festa a napoli ma è lui a natoli
forcaiola che non avevo capito anatolij
sarebbe il suo amico la gioia anatolia
e vabbè con le uscite che abc dal
anatolij dammi una bici bravo anatolij
bravo che amici sono se non escono dal
dal fiume attirarsi le bici grande
anatolij tramite le ruote al cane se
riesci no
le ruote al tizio le ruote a te stesso
alla bici le ruote la visione a
lasciarla così radici prendiamo il
motore mettilo la bici va bene la bici
slava ho potuto il motore ha una moto
l'ho messo io ero al motore quello
dell'altro l'ho messo alla bicicletta
giustamente eccolo
cosa chiesto se non sa chi 8 gigante mai
prendi milano non ho capito delle robe
ma scusami 1 non avevi fame
2 non dovevi andare a babooska 3 chi
minchia è quello orsacchiotto gigante
cose sono successe in questo livello
prova bene negli ultimi tempi la mia
vita assunto veramente poco senso però
ci convivo bene questa cosa ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto come se tanto
mi piace anche per boris e anatolij sono
stati e non ci vediamo ad un prossimo su
cup light berga
[Musica]